[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRADY HARAN: Do you
like it still?
ALAN STEWART: It's all right.
It's got a nice bounce to it.
BRADY HARAN: Hi there,
everyone.
I'm Brady from Numberphile.
And this is going to be bit of
a video with a difference
because I've come all the way
to Southampton to visit
someone I've never met in
the flesh until now.
He's real.
This is Alan Stewart.
And for those of you who watched
a few of my videos,
you'll be familiar with Alan's
work because he makes music,
as you probably guessed.
And he's put music on
loads of my videos.
And what we're going to do now,
before we get going, is
play you a bit of a montage of
some of the videos for which
Alan has composed his
masterpieces.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT PARKER: To get any kind
of accuracy on our final
answer, we have to be as
precise as we can be.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRADY HARAN: So that's some
examples of Alan's work.
Now very quickly, before we get
going, I must say early on
Alan has a YouTube channel,
ALANKEY86.
Subscribe to ALANKEY86.
Because if you do that, you
might make more music for me.
But also, Alan does loads
of other things.
He's always putting all sorts
of cool stuff on there.
Sometimes he just puts raw
tracks of the stuff he makes
for Numberphile.
But he also does all
of his own work.
And it's always full of really
interesting stuff.
So go and check it out.
ALANKEY86.
They'll be a link underneath
and on the screen and
everywhere.
And I'll sure we'll talk
about it more later.
So first thing's first,
we're going to get to
know the man himself.
And after we've spoken about
that, we're going to talk
about some of the music and some
of the maths and science
embedded in the music, which
will be really interesting.
First of all, I've been doing
a lot of talking here.
You want to say something?
ALAN STEWART: Yes.
I don't know what to say.
BRADY HARAN: Let me ask
you some questions.
ALAN STEWART: Thanks.
BRADY HARAN: The first thing we
should ask, because we'll
probably get asked about
it in the comments,
is about your eye.
Your two eyes are slightly
different.
And I know YouTube is--
they're not shy about writing
about what they see.
Should we talk about that?
What's going on there?
ALAN STEWART: Let's do that.
In my right eye, I have a
condition called band
keratopathy, which is a
buildup of mineral.
So it's just cloudy.
And I can't see out of
that eye at all.
My left eye is going
the same way.
So my vision in my left eye
is not perfect either.
BRADY HARAN: OK.
There you go.
Now you know.
So you probably don't need to
write thousands comments.
What's it's called again?
ALAN STEWART: Band
keratopathy.
BRADY HARAN: Band keratopathy.
There we go.
So now, let's find out
a bit about you.
You have a sort of a sciency
background or a mathematicky
background?
Talk to us.
ALAN STEWART: Yes.
I did a degree in physics at the
University of Southampton.
And I got my master's
there in 2008.
My musical background is
kind of nonexistent.
I had a piano lessons for two
years when I was a teenager.
Well, because of my eyesight, I
never learned to read music.
I can't physically see
the music to read it.
So that kind of limited
what I could do.
So I stopped having lessons.
But I continued to play and just
kind of taught myself.
BRADY HARAN: So you've
taught yourself.
You don't read or write music.
ALAN STEWART: No.
BRADY HARAN: If you don't
read or write
music, what do you do?
Do you just learn what
key sounds like what?
And when you press these in this
order, it sounds good?
ALAN STEWART: Yeah.
I play by ear.
So if I hear something, as long
as it's not like Bach or
something, I can usually
emulate it, try
and copy what I hear.
And I've been told I have
perfect pitch, which is like
the ability to hear a note and
just say, oh, that's an A. So
I guess that helps.
BRADY HARAN: OK.
Don't look.
What's this?
[NOTE PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: Oh.
Do you know?
BRADY HARAN: No.
You're all very quickly going
to learn that I have no idea
what any notes are.
Do you know?
ALAN STEWART: Sometimes I
have to think about it.
BRADY HARAN: I'll play
a different one.
It won't be the same one.
ALAN STEWART: Was it G?
BRADY HARAN: I don't know.
It was one of these ones.
ALAN STEWART: Go on, go
on, play it again.
BRADY HARAN: It was
one of these ones.
ALAN STEWART: One
of these ones.
BRADY HARAN: I don't even
know what one it was.
ALAN STEWART: And I
can play it again.
[NOTE PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: It was B.
BRADY HARAN: It was B.
ALAN STEWART: I was way off.
But I was able to
play it again.
BRADY HARAN: You were.
So what's that, semi-perfect
pitch, maybe?
ALAN STEWART: I think, yeah.
Perfect is a stretch.
Let's just say able to hear a
note and play it back again.
BRADY HARAN: Now you're not
a professional musician.
That's not how you
make your living.
ALAN STEWART: No.
BRADY HARAN: What's your job?
ALAN STEWART: I am a teacher.
I teach A-level physics at
Queen Mary's College.
I've been a teacher
for four years.
And I love it.
BRADY HARAN: People are
going to ask how we
ended up working together.
So tell us that story for
as long as it takes.
How did we end up working
together?
And go back as far
as you need.
ALAN STEWART: OK.
I think the first
thing I did--
I'm embarrassed about
it, though.
So I don't want to
talk about it.
BRADY HARAN: Really?
ALAN STEWART: Yeah.
BRADY HARAN: Is it criminal
or something?
ALAN STEWART: No, no.
It's that "Sixty
Symbols" song.
BRADY HARAN: Ahh, you made
a "Sixty Symbols" song.
ALAN STEWART: Yeah.
It wasn't very good.
It wasn't very cool.
BRADY HARAN: No, it
wasn't very cool.
ALAN STEWART: So I've actually
unlisted it now.
BRADY HARAN: Really?
ALAN STEWART: Yeah.
Because it wasn't as good as--
BRADY HARAN: Oh, well, I'm
going to tell everyone.
ALAN STEWART: No, you don't.
Don't.
BRADY HARAN: No, I'm
going to tell you.
I'm going to tell you.
Alan made little song about the
"Sixty Symbols." And he
sent it to me just to see if
I thought it was all right,
because you had used some of
our video footage, too.
ALAN STEWART: I had.
BRADY HARAN: You asked
permission.
And he was just saying that he
doesn't like it any more.
And he's unlisted the song.
He's embarrassed by it.
But I think it had some pretty
cool bits to it as well.
I thought it was
very Vangelis.
How do you say his name?
ALAN STEWART: Oh, Vangelis?
BRADY HARAN: Yeah.
Vangelis.
ALAN STEWART: Yeah.
BRADY HARAN: I thought bits of
it sounded quite like him.
I quite liked bits
of the song.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRADY HARAN: And as
a result of that--
ALAN STEWART: Yes, that's
the way it was.
BRADY HARAN: As a result of the
bits I liked, I asked you
if you'd compose some
more music.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: I think the first
bit of music I did was
for the Rubik's cube video,
where you had all the
different people solving
Rubik's cubes.
And I wrote some '80s
backing music.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-OK.
I actually git a pretty
easy case.
-Hello, YouTube.
And hello, Brady.
This is my Rubik's
cube attempt.
BRADY HARAN: I asked for it
to be kind of retro and
'80s, didn't I?
ALAN STEWART: Yeah.
But I also did some other
bits of music.
I think I sent you maybe four
or five different ideas.
And actually, you ended
up using all of them.
BRADY HARAN: On different
videos.
ALAN STEWART: On different
videos, yeah.
It wasn't my intention.
But you decided to use one for
Periodic Videos, and another
one later on in Numberphile.
BRADY HARAN: Well,
there you go.
It shows how good they were.
ALAN STEWART: Yeah.
BRADY HARAN: Let's talk
a bit about some of
these track, then.
We talked about the Rubik's
cube, where you
sent a whole bunch.
And I used them in
different videos.
ALAN STEWART: Yeah.
BRADY HARAN: None of them
were particularly
mathematical or science.
ALAN STEWART: None of them
had any particular
math element to them.
BRADY HARAN: OK.
Well, let's skip to
some that do.
Let's not go chronologically.
But let's go to one that I think
we should do with CERN.
And this is the Fibonacci
bagpipes.
ALAN STEWART: Fibonacci
BRADY HARAN: By way of
background, I should probably
give some background, because I
had a tartan made which was
based on the Fibonacci
sequence.
And as a result, I wanted some
sort of Scottish music that
was sort of imbued with
Fibonacciness.
And I sent an email to Alan.
Did I mention his
YouTube channel?
ALANKEY86.
I sent an email to Alan.
And one of the best things about
working with Alan is he
works so quickly.
I'm so lucky that people help
out with the YouTube channels.
And sometimes I'll
ask someone for
some music or an animation.
And because everyone's busy--
you're a busy man--
maybe a week or two later,
I might get a
response and some help.
But whenever I ask Alan for a
piece of music, sometimes
within half an hour or an
hour, I get an email of
something he's just composed
and played and recorded.
And the Fibonacci bagpipes, even
that was a really quick
turnaround.
ALAN STEWART: Thank you.
I just have nothing
better to do.
BRADY HARAN: You have nothing
ALAN STEWART: Being
a school teacher.
BRADY HARAN: There is nothing
better than helping out
Numberphile.
But anyway, so I wanted some
Scottish music imbued with
Fibonacci sequence.
And now I'll just play you a
little bit of the music as
that appeared in the video.
So let's play that now.
[BAGPIPE MUSIC PLAYING]
BRADY HARAN: Now I don't see
a set of bagpipes in here.
I'm guessing you don't
own a set.
ALAN STEWART: Certainly not.
BRADY HARAN: First of all, how
were you able to make a
bagpipe noise at all?
ALAN STEWART: Well, I feel like
I should acknowledge the
fact that it is just completely
synthesized in a
very unprofessional way.
BRADY HARAN: OK.
ALAN STEWART: I mixed together
trumpets and piccolos and
various presets on the keyboard
until I had something
that sounded squeaky and
slightly annoying.
BRADY HARAN: So it's just a
composite of other instruments
that sounds squeaky
and annoying.
ALAN STEWART: Layered on
top of each other.
BRADY HARAN: Yeah?
ALAN STEWART: Yeah.
BRADY HARAN: Can we
load that on?
Can we have a listen to
what they sound like?
ALAN STEWART: Here it is.
[NOTES PLAYING]
BRADY HARAN: So if you hit
different keys, like--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: Like that.
BRADY HARAN: OK.
So that's how we got
our bagpipes.
I tell you what, I'm going to
grab the camera, and you can
talk through the Fibonacciness
of it all.
ALAN STEWART: OK.
BRADY HARAN: Alan, you've
made bagpipe noise.
Talk to me about the
Fibonacciness of
this piece of music.
ALAN STEWART: OK.
The original piece is in B flat,
because that's what I
thought bagpipes
were tuned to.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: That's the
scale of B flat.
But I think to make it simpler
to explain, I'll actually play
it in C. So you can
number the notes.
Here's the very first note--
number 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
And then, of course, the eighth
note is the octave.
What I did was I took
the terms in
the Fibonacci sequence.
And I mapped them onto
the musical scale.
So the Fibonacci sequence
starts 1, 1, 2, 3, 5.
So that just comes out
as 1, 1, 2, 3, 5.
The next term is 8.
So I could jump up to
the eighth note.
But instead, I decided to take
it full circle and just go
back to the first note.
I mean, it's the same note.
It's still a C.
[NOTE PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: So that's
the eighth note.
So it goes 1, 1, 2, 3, 5, 8.
The next term in the Fibonacci
sequence is 13.
So I suppose I could
have continued to
climb up the keyboard.
The 13th note is--
[NOTE PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: --that.
The next term is 21.
The 21st note is--
[NOTE PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: --that.
But that will not sound nice.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: It doesn't
sound right.
So can I use maths?
Thanks.
What I did was I took
all the terms of
the Fibonacci sequence.
And I did mod 7 of the term,
which basically means if you
take the number-- there's
the Fibonacci number--
and divide it by 7, what
remainder are you left with?
So if you take, say, the number
8 and divide that by 7,
obviously you're going
to get 1 left over.
If you take 13 and divide that
by 7, you're going to have a
remainder of 6.
So in this column here, these
are the result of doing mod 7
on all the Fibonacci terms.
And this then allows you to map
the notes into one sort of
zone on the keyboard.
Well, it gives you 1, 1,
2, 3, 5, 1, 6, 0, 6,
6, 5, and so on.
Then I just took those numbers
and mapped them onto the C
Major scale.
BRADY HARAN: What do you get?
ALAN STEWART: You get this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: Which I've clearly
just played in an
awful way, because every note
had the same length.
So to give it a bit
more rhythm--
because the Scots like
their rhythm--
I just arbitrarily made the
notes whatever length I
thought sounded best.
So what you end up with is--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: Which has a bit
more of a lilt to it.
It just sounds more musical.
BRADY HARAN: I'm incredibly
impressed by this, because I
couldn't do this.
I'm impressed by anything
I can't do.
Cool.
ALAN STEWART: Can I just point
something out about the
Fibonacci sequence, though?
Is that there I just
played 16 notes.
So you may say, OK, well,
what's the 17th note?
It turns out that the 17th
note is note number 1.
[NOTE PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: The 18th notes
is note number 1.
[NOTE PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: The next note
is note number 2, and
then 3, and then 5.
And it turns out that it's
actually exactly the same
sequence again.
The same 16 notes just
keep on cycling.
I know we don't need
to show you this.
But on the spreadsheet, you can
just keep on going up the
Fibonacci sequence.
The remainder, the mod 7 number
just keeps cycling.
I don't know if I'm explaining
that well.
So there is no more to
the Fibonacci music.
I couldn't possibly have done
any more mapping, because it
just keeps repeating.
BRADY HARAN: Man,
that's awesome.
ALAN STEWART: Maybe.
BRADY HARAN: I'm sure there's
a perfectly logical reason.
ALAN STEWART: I'm
sure there is.
And being a physicist, I'm not
quite good enough at the maths
to be able to explain
why that is.
Maybe a numberphile will be able
to explain what is it.
BRADY HARAN: Excellent.
ALAN STEWART: Anyway.
That's one Fibonacci element.
The other thing is the tempo
is 89 beats per minute.
There's a pulse, click to the
music that just taps a regular
89 beats in a minute.
Now the drumming in the song
isn't just a simple pulse of
89 beats per minute.
BRADY HARAN: But where's
that pulse?
I can't hear a pulse.
ALAN STEWART: I had a click
track in Audacity that was
just constantly ticking at
89 beats per minutes.
BRADY HARAN: And then
you took that out?
ALAN STEWART: I took that out
just to keep me in time.
BRADY HARAN: So what is in
time with that, then?
What's happening 89
times in a minute?
Can you play the track for me?
Play the click track.
ALAN STEWART: Yeah, sure.
[CLICK TRACK PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: There you go.
That's what 89 beats per
minute sounds like.
And I just make sure that I kept
in time with that as I
was playing.
So I was going--
[MUSIC AND CLICK
TRACK PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: Of course, I took
the click track out after
I'd finished recording, because
no one wants to heat a
click track.
[CLICK TRACK PLAYING]
BRADY HARAN: But Alan, I don't
really know what--
because some notes you do are
short, and some are long.
They don't all hit.
What is the thing that's keeping
in time with that
click track?
Does every fourth note have
to hit the boot pedal?
I don't know what you mean by
keeping in time with that.
ALAN STEWART: Oh, dear.
That's such a difficult
question.
OK.
BRADY HARAN: Play it.
And talk to me of what
you're thinking
and what you're doing.
ALAN STEWART: You ask
a lot, Brady.
BRADY HARAN: This is how these
videos get made, right?
ALAN STEWART: Right.
So I suppose I could play it
so that every note lands on
one of the clicks.
So I could play.
[NOTES PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: Except the click
track just stopped, because it
was only 32 bars.
BRADY HARAN: Start again.
ALAN STEWART: I'll
start again.
I'll just loop it.
BRADY HARAN: Yeah.
ALAN STEWART: There we go.
It's on loop.
[CLICK TRACK PLAYING]
BRADY HARAN: But you don't do
that, because that sound
boring, is that right?
ALAN STEWART: Yeah.
BRADY HARAN: Then what
do you do instead?
If you're going to break the
rules and not follow the click
track, what's the point
of the click track?
ALAN STEWART: Well, maybe if I
talk about breaking the rules,
when I break the rules, I'm
taking the time interval
between one click and
the next click.
And I'm cutting it in
half, for example.
So when one click happens, I
might play two notes of the
same length.
So I'll just try and
demonstrate that.
[MUSIC AND CLICK
TRACK PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: No.
That was notes on the click.
Let me try and demonstrate.
This is quite difficult.
[NOTES PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: There.
That's what it would sound like
to have half the click
separation as a note.
And I think that's how
all music and all
rhythm is made up.
You take the click track.
And then the space in between
the clicks, you cut
it perhaps in half.
Or you cut it into three
pieces or cut
it into four pieces.
And usually you stick to notes
of those durations, so half a
click or a third of a click.
BRADY HARAN: But, Alan, if you
put two notes between clicks,
aren't you playing at 178
beats per minute?
ALAN STEWART: I suppose you
could say that I was, except
that not every note is two
notes between the clicks.
Some of the notes are just
the duration between one
click and the next.
BRADY HARAN: Do you
ever skip a beat?
ALAN STEWART: Oh,
yeah, sometimes.
Everything I do in this song
is some multiple of that or
some division of that.
I guess that's what rhythm is.
BRADY HARAN: All right.
Let's turn that off then,
that little click.
So now we know that
89, a Fibonacci
number, plays a big role.
What else you got in there?
ALAN STEWART: Drums.
I really just need to change the
drum kit on the keyboard,
which I know to be number
86, I think.
No, that's the Cuban
percussion kit.
[NOTES PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: Sounds nice,
though, doesn't it?
I particularly like this one.
[NOTES PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: This is the
orchestral percussion kit on
the keyboard.
And it's got some nice, low
drums, tympani possibly, or
I'm not sure.
And it's also got some
snare drums.
[SNARE DRUMS PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: And it's
got snare roll.
[SNARE ROLL PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: So you can
generate a sort of drum track,
I suppose, for the song.
So in the Fibonacci bagpipes, I
used the drums to mark out,
first of all, one accent,
one loud note.
[NOTE PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: One.
And then the next term in the
Fibonacci sequence is 1 as
well, so another one of those.
[NOTE PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: And then 2.
[NOTES PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: And then 3.
ALAN STEWART: And then 5.
[NOTES PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: And those can be
heard underneath the bagpipes
about halfway through
the track.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRADY HARAN: That's my favorite
bit, by the way.
ALAN STEWART: When everything
comes in?
BRADY HARAN: I like
how they're going
at Fibonacci numbers.
Maybe that's because it's the
only bit I recognized.
ALAN STEWART: Yeah.
I think it's punctuated.
It stands out.
And of course, there's also
the snare drumming.
I could have done some clever
Fibonaccis with the snares.
But instead, I wanted it to
remain musical sounding.
Because I think if I'd based all
of the drum rhythms on the
Fibonacci sequence, it would
stop sounding musical.
So for that snare drums,
I just did some
typical snare drumming.
BRADY HARAN: Do it again.
Do it again.
[NOTES PLAYING]
BRADY HARAN: So there's
no Fibonacci there?
ALAN STEWART: No.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: There's one more
thing, one more element.
In the chorus, if you will,
we hear this melody.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: Very short.
That is the same melody as
Philip Moriarty and Dave Brown
used in the phi song.
[MUSIC - "GOLDEN RATIO SONG"]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: Now what does phi
have to do with Fibonacci
numbers, Brady may ask.
BRADY HARAN: What does
phi have to do with
the Fibonacci numbers?
ALAN STEWART: If you take two
consecutive Fibonacci numbers
and you do the bigger one
divided by the little one,
then the result is close
to the golden
ratio, close to phi.
Now obviously, if you choose
little Fibonacci numbers, like
8 and 5, that comes
out to be--
panic--
8/5.
What's that?
1.4, which is not very close.
But if you use larger Fibonacci
numbers, it tends
towards the golden ratio.
It gets closer and closer and
closer to the golden ratio.
Proportion is divine.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[MUSIC - "GOLDEN RATIO SONG"]
ALAN STEWART: Very nice.
The proportion is divine.
BRADY HARAN: You have this
mathematical, sciency
background--
and not even a background.
You're a physics teacher.
And you have this interest
in music.
To what extent is music this
arty experience for you?
And to what extent are you
thinking very much about
numbers and octaves and science
and dividing beats
into factors and things?
ALAN STEWART: I think that's
a really good question.
And I would say none at all.
I don't think in terms
of mathematics.
of the science of it.
I just literally play what
I think sounds good.
However, if I want to compose
a piece which is based on,
say, the Fibonacci sequence or
pi, then I can use maths to
map it onto music and art.
And so I feel like there
is a crossover.
But I'm not conscious of
it when I'm playing.
BRADY HARAN: So when I drop
you an email and say,
can you help me?
Can you come up with some
music based on this
mathematical principle, how
much is that putting a
straitjacket on you?
And how much is that making
it more fun and enjoyable?
ALAN STEWART: I think
sometimes having a
straitjacket, having a very
specific brief can actually
really help.
Because if you're just told to
compose some background music
for, I don't know,
an elephant--
actually, no.
That's probably quite easy
to do, actually.
But if you were just asked to
compose a nice piece of music,
where do you start?
Whereas if you're asked to
compose a piece of music
that's based on Fibonacci, then
that does actually help
to have the restriction.
BRADY HARAN: Well, speaking of
restrictions, another request
that I put in to you was to help
with some music for our
video about calculating pi
with pies, which was an
interesting video, and certainly
attracted some
interesting comments, not
because of your music, but
because of our use of pies.
But let's not go into that.
Let's talk about the music.
Do you remember what
I asked you for?
I can't even remember
what I asked.
I told you what we were doing.
ALAN STEWART: You told me that
you were going to measure pi
using laser pi's and you
wanted something
quirky, you asked for.
No.
What did you ask for?
BRADY HARAN: There was some kind
of toing and froing on
this one, wasn't there?
Did you send me something,
and I--
ALAN STEWART: Yes.
No.
I think what it was was I think
you said you were going
to do a video--
yes.
You said you were going to do
a video where you were going
to measure pi using pies.
And could I come up
with some music?
It could be based
on pi, you said.
And I thought, it's got
to be based on pi.
Because if it's not
based on pi, then
what's the point, really?
So I sent you some just very
light piano music with a
classical feel.
It was very backgroundy, very
similar to the "Spaghetti
Numbers" music.
BRADY HARAN: Well, let's
play that now, because
I still have that.
Let's play what Alan
first sent.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: You
weren't unhappy.
You said it was nice.
But then I asked you, because
you described
the activity to me.
I asked you, was there any
sense of it being a bit
sneaky, like you were doing
something you weren't supposed
to be doing?
Because what I'd done was
I played around a
but more with pi.
And I discovered that on a minor
scale, as opposed to a
major scale, it had a very
different feel to it.
And I'd come up with something
that I thought sounded quite--
James Bondy was how I worded
it in my email to you.
BRADY HARAN: I believe so.
ALAN STEWART: So yeah.
BRADY HARAN: We ended up with
something different.
ALAN STEWART: We did, yeah.
Something with a little bit
more tension to it.
BRADY HARAN: A lot of people who
I showed the video said it
wasn't what--
because I told a lot of people
like my friends and things
what I was doing, and that you
were making some music.
And then when I showed them the
cut piece, a lot of them
said that's completely
not what I expected
the music to be like.
ALAN STEWART: Oh, really?
BRADY HARAN: And it
works really well.
ALAN STEWART: Oh, that's cool.
BRADY HARAN: It was kind of like
I think everyone who had
an expectation of what that
video was going to be like was
thrown a bit of a curve ball.
But I still really like it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT PARKER: My goal is to not
actually do any measurement
other than using pies.
So the entire thing is going
to be pie based.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT PARKER: We get the
circumference in the exact
number of pies, give or take.
BRADY HARAN: Shall we talk to
people about the music and
tell them about how you
embedded pi in it?
ALAN STEWART: Yes.
BRADY HARAN: Let me go
and get the camera.
Let's do it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: I come up with
very boring names, which are
just for my benefit to remind
me what the feel of it is.
I think this one was probably
just called--
oh, no, wait.
No, this had an important
name.
This was called "Pi March,"
because musically it's similar
to a march, like a
marching band.
And Pi Day is in March.
BRADY HARAN: Very good.
By the way, if anyone's hearing
the construction work
outside, there's nothing
we can do about that.
It's because Alan's having
another house built, because
he's a millionaire.
ALAN STEWART: OK.
So again, I don't know
how to describe it.
It's very conventional to map,
I think, the digits of a
number onto a scale.
And with Fibonacci, we were
putting the numbers of the
Fibonacci sequence on to the
notes of the C major scale,
these ones.
[NOTES PLAYING]
BRADY HARAN: OK.
Yeah.
ALAN STEWART: So just to be
different, just to be
outrageous, I thought, let's
put pi on a minor scale.
So here's the scale.
BRADY HARAN: And why
is that outrageous?
ALAN STEWART: Because
I'm using hyperbole.
BRADY HARAN: Obviously
you're exaggerating.
ALAN STEWART: Sorry.
BRADY HARAN: It's
not outrageous.
ALAN STEWART: No, sorry.
BRADY HARAN: Why is that
outside the box?
Or why is that a twist?
ALAN STEWART: Sure.
Well, there have been quite
a few people who
have put pi to music--
Vi Hart, for one, and
some other people.
And there's a very well-known
video called "The Sounds of
Pi," I think.
In all of the videos I've ever
seen, they've always put pi on
a major scale.
Professor Moriarty put pi on a
major scale on the guitar.
[ROCK MUSIC PLAYING]
PHILIP MORIARTY: 3, 1, 4, 1, 5,
9, bend up to 9, back to 2.
And then we've got
6, 5, 3, 5, 8, 9.
ALAN STEWART: So I thought I'd
like to hear what it sounds
like on a minor scale,
just to see.
And it sounds quite different.
BRADY HARAN: Go on.
ALAN STEWART: I need
to play it.
OK.
So first of all, the notes of
the minor scale go like this.
[NOTES PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: So a very
different feel.
It's a sad scale, as my piano
teacher would have said.
The third note.
[NOTE PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: The first note.
ALAN STEWART: The fourth note.
[NOTE PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: The first note.
ALAN STEWART: The fifth note.
[NOTE PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: The ninth.
ALAN STEWART: The second.
[NOTE PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: And
then the sixth.
[NOTE PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: And the fifth.
ALAN STEWART: So just then, I
played it pretty much on a
pulse, just boring.
[NOTES PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: Which to me, it
didn't really have much of a
rhythm to it.
So again, I just arbitrarily
made the notes as long as I
wanted them to be until
it sounded good.
There's actually a rest at the
start which I have to play
with the left hand.
Sorry.
It goes--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: And that rhythm
I thought sounded good.
And that's what I
ended up with.
BRADY HARAN: What were
you doing there?
Was that breaking the rules?
Or was that part of pi as well,
that little thing you do
with your left hand?
Or is that just a little bit of
a flourish you put in for
musical reasons?
ALAN STEWART: That was the arty,
musical side of me, and
has nothing to do with math.
It's just me making
it sound good.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRADY HARAN: OK.
So the notes were based on pi.
You went a bit further,
didn't you, as usual?
ALAN STEWART: Yeah.
Yeah.
The tempo, the number of
beats per minute, was
some multiple of pi.
It was 104 beats per minute.
BRADY HARAN: Why is that?
What's that?
ALAN STEWART: That's pi
multiplied by 33.3 recurring.
What I did was pi times
100 divided by 3.
BRADY HARAN: What else
was marching?
There were drums and things,
weren't there?
ALAN STEWART: In the "Pi March,"
yes, yes, the same
drum beats that were in the
Fibonacci, the same
principles.
So the first digit of pi is 3.
So there were 3 blasts on drum,
and then one blast on
the drum, and then 4.
And I think that stands out.
That's quite obvious.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT PARKER: This is a mild
problem, because I want to go
from the very edge
of the circle.
But as you can see, I've
positioned all the pies.
BRADY HARAN: What's it like for
you when you make a bit of
music like you do for people
like me, and then you see the
video on YouTube with
your music on it?
What's that like?
ALAN STEWART: I love it.
I'm always really excited if
it's going to be a video with
some music.
And I guess--
I don't know.
It makes it come alive.
BRADY HARAN: Is it
different for you
when you see the video?
I say, this is what the
video is about.
Do you feel like, no, that's not
what I expected the video
to be like, or how I expected
my music to used?
ALAN STEWART: I think usually
your editing fits really well
with the music.
So in the pi video, you cut
on the beat, for example.
Or you would cut at the
end of a phrase.
And so I was really delighted
with how it looked in the end.
It matched the music.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRADY HARAN: Do you
like it still?
ALAN STEWART: It's all right.
It's got a nice bounce to it.
I don't know what else to say.
BRADY HARAN: You don't like
listening to you own music?
ALAN STEWART: I guess
I play it.
I practice it.
I record it.
I listen to it.
And so after you've heard it
like 50 times, it loses its
initial excitement and
the feeling that
you get from there.
And it just becomes a
song you've heard
too much on the radio.
But to begin with, when I first
came up with that, I
just, I don't know, smiling
to myself, it
just sounded so good.
I like making something up.
And I enjoy it for the
first hour or so.
BRADY HARAN: I've made a little
list here of some of
the other bits of music that I
particularly enjoy, because I
just wanted to ask you a bit
about the making of them.
ALAN STEWART: Yeah.
BRADY HARAN: Our "Good
Will Hunting" video.
Because we made a video about
mathematics in "Good Will
Hunting." I emailed and said
basically, can you make
something that sounds like the
theme music from "Good Will
Hunting?" Because I can't
use the actual music.
And you came up with this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRADY HARAN: Which
I really liked.
It really sounds like the theme
of "Good Will Hunting,"
without being it.
Tell us about how you
came up with that,
because I'm really curious.
ALAN STEWART: Yeah.
So I mean I've seen "Good Will
Hunting." But I can't say I
remembered the music.
So I went on YouTube.
And I just searched for
the theme tune.
And I listened to it probably
for about an hour just in the
background, just having
it there.
I felt like I was trying
to soak it up.
And there were certain parts of
it-- because it's quite a
complicated piece of music.
There's loads going on.
And it's a bit crazy.
But there were parts of it that
I thought I can emulate
what Danny Elfman, the composer,
has done here.
So there's the high-pitched,
piccolo-like
sound at the beginning.
And then there's also something
quite beautiful
about it, but also something
slightly discordant.
Like in the introduction, those
piano chords are not
what I would think of
as normal chords.
They're a bit dissonant.
They're a bit odd.
So taking all those different
bits that I soaked up from it,
I just tried to write something
that sounded similar.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRADY HARAN: When you listen
to something for a hour,
though, like when a song gets
stuck in your head, how do you
stop that being so stuck in
your head that you can be
original with it?
ALAN STEWART: I think the "Good
Will Hunting" theme tune
is quite unique in that, even
after listening to it for an
hour, I still find it quite
unpredictable, because it is
such an interesting, rich
piece of music.
There's so much going
on in it.
Actually, that's why I had to
listen to it for so long.
Because normally if I hear a
song four or five times, I can
usually just play
it after that.
But yeah, that theme tune
is complicated.
So I didn't get tired of it.
BRADY HARAN: Is your mimic, is
your homage to it equally
unpredictable?
ALAN STEWART: No.
My homage to it is simple
by comparison.
I feel like mine is a little
bit more tuneful.
There's an actual tune that
you could sing along to.
Whereas in Danny Elfman's score,
it's quite a random
piece of music.
And I challenge anyone to sing
the theme tune to "Good Will
Hunting." Whereas, I think
mine, you could
actually sing it back.
BRADY HARAN: All right.
Well, if anyone sings the
theme tune to "Good Will
Hunting," or if they sings
Alan's version of it and post
it as a video response, I will
allow the video response.
ALAN STEWART: That'll
be great.
BRADY HARAN: Because that
would be quite a sight.
ALAN STEWART: It would.
It's such a weird piece.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRADY HARAN: Well, another
piece of music, this is
actually more of a project
that you did quite
independently of what
I was doing.
And that's the "Dragon
Curve" music.
ALAN STEWART: Oh, yeah.
BRADY HARAN: Obviously, we did
a video about the "Dragon
Curve." And there are
other animations
that have been done.
And you contacted the animator
and you made your own piece of
music to that animation.
ALAN STEWART: Hmm.
BRADY HARAN: And then we sort
of brought it all together
into a Numberphile video.
ALAN STEWART: Yeah.
BRADY HARAN: That's obviously a
really nice piece of music.
Is that mathematical
or inspired?
Or was that just you making
a nice piece of music?
ALAN STEWART: I'd say that the
mathematical link is even
weaker than the pi song,
Fibonacci song.
But to me, it does reflect
things about the curve, about
the shape, the way it unfolds.
There are parts of it that, to
me, do connect with the shape.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: It's quite
difficult to explain.
But one thing, actually,
about the
animation is that it rotates.
And so in my head, I had
the idea of circles.
And in music, there's
this thing called
the Circle of Fifths.
And I wanted to use the Circle
of Fifths somewhere in the
song to reflect that rotation
of the animation.
There was something about the
animation that just looked
like the original one that
looked quite lonely.
And it was just a fractal
forming slowly in
a vast black space.
So I wanted something
that sounded lonely.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN STEWART: Shall I
carry on talking?
BRADY HARAN: Nah, you
can stop now.
ALAN STEWART: Yeah.
BRADY HARAN: One more thing, and
this is not Numberphile.
It wasn't for a Numberphile
video.
It was for a Deep Sky Video.
ALAN STEWART: Yeah.
BRADY HARAN: And as far as I,
know there's no math or
science involved.
But it's actually my favorite
piece of music that you've
made for me.
So I wanted to ask you about
it and hear a bit about the
story from your end.
And that's a piece of music that
you called "Time Passes."
ALAN STEWART: Oh, yes.
BRADY HARAN: I'll tell
it from my end first.
Basically, I was in Paris.
And I went to Charles
Messier's grave.
And I'm going to stop now,
because the battery is about
to run out.
I'm going to change the
battery in the camera.
As I was saying,
I was in Paris.
And I went to Charles
Messier's grave.
And I wanted a piece of music to
reflect us walking through
the cemetery.
And I emailed to you.
ALAN STEWART: Uh-huh.
BRADY HARAN: Basically I just
said, I've just been walking
through a cemetery.
And I want a piece of music that
shows me walking through
a cemetery.
And really quickly, while I was
still in the hotel, you
sent me a few options
from memory.
And I really liked
all of them.
They were all really lovely.
I could have used any of them.
But in the end, I
used this one.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRADY HARAN: I thought
I read about it.
Straight ahead to the right of
the monument, and then right.
[MUSIC - ALAN STEWART,
"TIMES PASSES"]
BRADY HARAN: What happened when
I sent you this email to
result in these pieces
of music?
ALAN STEWART: I think I find
it easier to write
sad-sounding music.
So you said you were
in a cemetery.
So I thought, it's
got to sound sad.
You also said that the video
was going to feature you
traveling to the place.
So I wanted something that had a
bit of movement to it, a bit
of motion, which is why it's
got a fairly fast pulse.
It's like a ticking
of a clock.
And that's why I called it
"Time Passes" as well.
BRADY HARAN: Well, I liked it.
ALAN STEWART: Thank you.
BRADY HARAN: Well done.
ALAN STEWART: Thanks.
[MUSIC - ALAN STEWART,
"TIMES PASSES"]
BRADY HARAN: Thank you for all
the bits of music you have
made for the Numberphile
videos.
I know from the comments under
the videos that people
watching also enjoy them.
And a final reminder, ALANKEY86
is the YouTube channel.
Go and subscribe.
Let me tell you the main reason
I want you subscribe.
It's because every time I link
to Alan's channel, I get an
email from him where he says,
oh, five new people have
subscribed.
And he gets really excited and
says he knows when I put a
video up, because he'll have 10
new subscribers or 30 new
subscribers.
And I feel a bit disappointed
that so few people subscribe
after all the hard
work you put in.
So if a whole bunch of you go
and subscribe, well, that
would be good, wouldn't it?
ALAN STEWART: Thank you.
BRADY HARAN: Yeah.
Why should they subscribe,
though?
They shouldn't just do it
to be nice to me or you.
What are they going
to get if they do?
ALAN STEWART: They will
get piano music.
I try and upload maybe once a
week or once a fortnight,
something I've written,
some composition.
Occasionally, I'll do something
a bit different,
like a song.
BRADY HARAN: All right.
ALAN STEWART: Yeah.
BRADY HARAN: And just as a
little teaser, I know, because
we were talking off camera,
that Alan is working on a
couple of new compositions which
hopefully might appear
on Numberphile, if I can
secure the rights.
And you're doing them with
Professor Phil Moriarty, who
also appears in Numberphile
in Sixty Symbols.
And I have had bit
of a preview.
And they're pretty exciting.
They're pretty quirky.
ALAN STEWART: They're
a bit different.
BRADY HARAN: They
are different.
One of them I really like.
One of them I like for
its craziness.
So that will be coming soon.
So stay tuned to Numberphile and
Sixty Symbols, but also to
ALANKEY86, because Alan puts
a lot of his raw material.
And videos of him playing the
pieces appear on that channel.
So it's always a good little
supplementary to some of the
stuff you see on Numberphile.
Those long, slender
piano fingers--
there we go--
which are so famous
on your channel.
ALAN STEWART: Thank you.
BRADY HARAN: Thank
you for watching.
I don't know how long this
video is going to be.
We've recorded 54
or 55 minutes.
ALAN STEWART: Wow.
BRADY HARAN: That's a load.
Do you think we can put 55
minutes on Numberphile?
ALAN STEWART: No.
BRADY HARAN: People
won't watch that.
ALAN STEWART: I don't
think so.
BRADY HARAN: I'll cut
the bits out.
I'll cut the bit out where
you got really
abusive and started swearing.
ALAN STEWART: Yeah.
BRADY HARAN: All right.
[MUSIC PLAYING]